[Music]
light walking's you come bearing gifts
my friend I did you brought me this
beautiful meditation blankets because I
know you like Tomatoes we're burning
your incense that you brought I love it
and these cool promos for the book that
you hang on your door saying meditation
in progress that's very clever I love it
man it's cool good to see you man it's
good to be back at you you I've had a
lot of podcast interviews and this is by
far one of my favorite ones and I am a
big fan of the show in general and of
you and the way you approach these
interviews and you're very kind of real
and accessible you know Tony Hsieh no BS
and I just I just love it thank you man
I really appreciate that well you were
on originally had to be at least two
years ago couple years definitely it was
just after I published my first book the
inner Jim mm-hmm and so we were talking
about happiness and all of that right
right right right and now you're back
I'm in the midst of a little bit of a
meditation jazz that's right I just put
up my my episode with Dan Harris and
then yesterday I had Bob Roth in here
yeah and now you're here it's a sign of
the times you know I think you see this
in diet a lot a lot of different types
of diet books and I think now and people
are really not just interested in
meditation but learning about different
approaches to meditation so you have a
lot of a lot of activity in the
publishing world around this yeah for
sure I asked this to Bob but I'll ask it
of you as well why now like why do you
think this is all why is there this
convergence this confluence of
conversation and dialogue and interest
and meditation like what's happening
right now that you think is creating
this desire and this interest I think
just like how the pendulum is swinging
politically in our country you know
towards this kind of extremism
we're also swinging in a certain
direction of comparison and you know
social media and technology and and the
digital age is
is causing us to feel more isolated than
ever before
that in addition to we're catching the
tail end of the yoga comet you know and
then and that almost always leads to
some form of meditation mm-hmm because
we've gone through all the different
iterations the hip-hop yoga and this
yoga yoga and so okay so what what when
you extrapolate all these different
approaches what is it actually leading
to its leading to meditation and so only
in it was only a matter of time before
we started making meditation the
forefront of the conversation and I
think meditation today is still where
yoga was probably 20 years ago I think
that's probably right I think what's
interesting about yoga is that the true
intention of yoga really is meditation
at its core the asana are all designed
to still the mind and prepare you for
the shavasana at the end and that sort
of gets lost in the conversation you
know yeah it's really they're all just a
precursor to trying to achieve some you
know sort of state of equanimity so that
you can be still also though with social
media I think that anything that is
starting to feel to hit critical mass in
the wellness bubbles it tends to spread
a lot faster mm-hmm and you also have
people who are very masterful at
marketing these kinds of things you know
getting on board early and taking
advantage of the marketing opportunities
so then you have a lot of competition
between those different outfits and
people hear that oh this app got funded
for this amount of money let me create
an app and you know and so I think
that's also another reason why a lot of
people are talking about it just because
it's in the marketing mm-hmm ethos as
well yeah it it's being commodified
exactly which is what happened to yoga
right and and there's there's a good
aspect of that I think as long as you're
you're not losing sight of what it is at
its core like what is is what it what
it's actually all about rather than you
know what are the tights that you're
wearing or right you know what is the
pillow that you're sitting on which is
why
I think all these all of us are writing
these books is because we want to try to
preserve some semblance of evening of
history or tradition when it comes to
these different approaches to the
practice right what is your opinion on
all the apps and all of that butts out
there
you know honestly I'm a big fan of
anything that anyone does to own onboard
themselves in the practice of meditation
I think that people graduate from
different platforms we know when they
get more serious and when they when
their natural curiosity kind of leads
them to a deeper investment in them in
themselves and I and you know so there's
there's something for everybody at this
point mm-hmm yeah I mean I think that we
need it now more than ever we're more
stressed were more anxious were more
depressed than we've ever been and
despite these technological tools that
are supposed to unite us and bring us
together we've never been more divided
as a culture and I think the level of
anxiety right now that people are
experiencing just in their day to day
lives
aside from just what it takes to get
through the day is that a is that a peak
that I haven't seen in my own life
experience and so where are you gonna go
from that right like you can medicate
yourself or you can begin to take care
of yourself and I think the discovery of
meditation as this incredibly powerful
tool to combat you know what everyone is
experiencing you know from a negative
perspective in their life is
unbelievably powerful and you my friend
play a large role in this movement
yeah and it's it's largely I think
listen oh because thank you right now no
but I think meditation is out obviously
I think it's wonderful but it's still
it's I'm in the root cause business and
it's like the band-aid guys are getting
good at yeah for the same reason people
would rather you know pop a Viagra they
clean up their diet this way you know
what I mean everyone wants the quick fix
everyone wants the life hack everyone
wants the pill or the band-aid
and our system our society our culture
is structured around prioritizing those
over the root cause and the genesis that
is giving rise to these conditions to
begin with mm-hmm yep so but it feels a
little like selling meditation which is
what essentially all of us are doing
right if you're a meditation teacher to
some extent you're selling people on the
idea that their life would be better if
they meditated it's still kind of like
you're you're you know dentist living in
your hands where nobody brushes their
teeth and you're trying to tell people
this toothbrush if you just brush all of
your dental problems were just that you
wouldn't have them anymore and it's it's
it's a hard sell sometimes to some
people whose eyes could kind of gloss
over when you write I mean I was talking
about this with Bob yesterday I mean
he's been doing it for 45 years you know
what I mean but now there's an awareness
that that you know is reaching this peak
level that he's never seen in his
experience as somebody who's been
teaching since the late 1960s right and
you've been at it for a while it's not
like you're johnny-come-lately yeah I've
been in it about 20 years so it has to
be cool and gratifying for you as well
to see this level of interest and
something that you've been passionate
about in practicing for so long yeah and
what I like about what Bob Roth and
David Lynch and those guys are doing is
they're being very active about taking
it into inner cities and taking it into
the veterans hospitals and things like
that yeah I was amazing on the front
lines yeah people who really need it and
that's one of the that was one of the
motivations behind me writing the book
that I did because you know I think that
there are certain populations of people
who aren't necessarily you know in
school or haven't necessarily served in
the military but they're out there
struggling they may be blue-collar they
may be driving trucks or flipping
burgers and they don't they couldn't
afford to come and sit with someone like
me for four days and have me train them
and write and how to become a
self-sufficient meditator but these
principles would still apply to them
wherever they are and I wanted to I
wanted to to access those people and
give them some of this knowledge so that
they can benefit from it in real-world
ways yeah absolutely I mean I think it
begs a larger question around
what wellness means in general and and
and the effort required to kind of rebut
or overcome this presumption that it is
the purview of the well-heeled
that it is you know this elitist thing
that you know only you know people with
six six-figure incomes can afford to
indulge themselves with and when you
look at you know what Bob and the David
Lynch foundation are doing with inmates
and prisons and veterans with PTSD and
going into inner-city schools and
teaching these at-risk youths how to do
this I mean it's it's really cool I mean
you know Bob gets a lot of attention for
all the fancy people that he teaches and
I know you teach fancy people as well
but really that's what it's about right
it's about how can we raise the bar of
consciousness across the board and you
know if I'm being honest there is a bit
of a trickle-down effect because you
know a lot of the people who are big
proponents of meditation are in the
wellness bubbles on the coasts in LA and
New York and these are the people who
are writing and producing the movies and
the tale television shows and the
articles that sure people will read yeah
like my brother who used to be a parole
officer prison guard actually in Alabama
he said he started metod he's he's known
a taught meditation for many many years
but he never meditated they said he read
about it in Newsweek one day and it
started like infuriate you like look
I've been talking about this forever you
had to read the second Newsweek in order
that's how it works you know I know in
that especially certain parts of the
country people don't believe in unless
they see it on the news or unless they
see it on the morning shows and things
like that and that's right that's like
my crazy brother lives in Venice you
know it's like this fringe character
yeah right so since it's been a couple
years since you've been on the show is
probably worth recapping like your
journey into this world like yeah but
what got you interested at the beginning
well to start from the very very
beginning I grew up in the South in
Alabama and as far away from meditation
as you could possibly get and was had a
pretty nice childhood you know nothing
traumatic happened and went to college
graduated from college and
started working in advertising and
interestingly I looked around the office
and it was a great job it was in the
creative Department and I just didn't
really I didn't have the language for it
at the time but I looked around in it
and and I didn't see anybody who was I
felt like was happy mm-hmm and I looked
at the people who had been there the
longest the most senior people the ones
making all the money and they didn't
strike me as being particularly
fulfilled and like I said I didn't know
the language for all that at the time I
just there was something that felt a bit
off mmm and for me for me personally and
work for where I felt like I was going
and so I decided to leave that situation
and I just started travelling around and
I got started dabbling in the fashion
industry I started modeling a bit and
did that for about six or seven years
that took me literally around the world
and got a taste of a lot of different
societies and cultures and people and
then after that I kind of decided that
you know I wanted to use more of my
gifts and talents I didn't want to just
stand in front of a camera posing for
pictures and then spending a month
hoping someone calls me to tell me I won
the beauty pageant that day right and
and I wanted to I've been dabbling in
yoga I was living in New York and I
started doing meditation circles and I
didn't know anyone else who was doing
this I just everyone in yoga talked
about meditation and this was back this
is back in the mid 90s when even in the
gym yoga classes it was very serious
there was no music there was no you know
the people who were teaching were people
who had who had been trained in yoga
retreats and yoga centers and so we were
meditating in a very serious way you
know we were sitting in circles and and
everything was very traditional legs
crossed and my secret was that I was
never feeling anything I never felt like
anything was happening I just thought
you know okay I'm assuming the position
maybe just thinking about thinking was
what you're supposed to do and then
you're just supposed to pretend like it
was this profound
period right everyone's just faking it
right and I would peek and look around
and see and everyone was just kind of
sitting there with their you know and I
didn't know when they were experiencing
I just knew what I was experiencing and
so I tried different variations of that
of meditation and still nothing quite
felt like I wasn't using my imagination
and this went on for two or three years
and I finally after I left them fashion
industry I moved to Los Angeles with the
intention of becoming a yoga teacher and
within about a month I this other yoga
teacher who there was something about
him he had a level of contentedness that
I hadn't really seen before than anyone
else so we started hanging out and he
would always bring up meditation and
again I didn't know anyone else who was
meditating I knew a lot of people who
were doing yoga but back then nobody in
yoga was necessarily taking time to
meditate outside of maybe you know two
minutes at the end of the yoga class
where you're sitting there with your
legs crossed back straight hoping
something was gonna happen so he always
brings up meditation and I reluctantly
agree to meditate with him and we do it
in every kind of situation before we go
to the movies before we go to a hike
before we go to lunch still nothing's
happening I had received no instruction
and all meanwhile I'm feeling like a lot
of persistence for like hanging in there
right somebody is like not getting
anything out of it well here's deal I'm
leading meditations in my yoga class so
at the end of the class I'm telling
everybody we're gonna cuz that's what
you're supposed to do yeah I didn't know
meanwhile I hadn't received any
meditation instruction at all and then
finally this guy this friend of mine
says hey my meditation teachers coming
to town in a month I want you to come
and meet him and this completely blew my
mind I didn't I didn't even know
meditation teachers existed because I
had never heard of one or met one before
and so I met this guy at his apartment a
month later and this guy ended up being
the happiest person I'd ever seen in my
entire life was that Tom Knowles yeah
yeah yeah we talked about this last yeah
and I knew within about 10 minutes I
wanted that's what I want to do I want
to I want what he has
and I want to do what he does for a
living was it
that apartment that was like off
fountain on Laurel Avenue yeah did you
go there
well I went to one I had a friend who
brought me to one of those in a similar
fashion he's like coming you know me
he's got this thing meet this guy and
there were maybe 30 people there I had a
couple friends that were there I
remember Anna David was there my friend
Anna do you know Anna yeah she actually
I think she went and learn with Tom yeah
I think that's right I think that's
right and I remember I mean this was a
long time ago yeah this or whatever back
in like the early the early 2000s yeah
exactly it's probably 2001 or two or
something like that
and I remember being impacted by it but
I was like broke at the time I couldn't
afford like I just it didn't stick with
me at that moment but I was moved by the
presentation that yeah like I was like
this is clearly working for these people
and because I knew some of the people
there it wasn't like oh I walked into
some weird cult I was probably there now
you might have been there as after I was
in the first wave of students and then
after that I just wanted to hang out as
much as I could do you know did you know
Andrew wheeler yeah of course one he's
the one who brought yeah yeah yeah yeah
of course I know Andrew yeah he was
around a lot and I was there setting up
chairs and ushering people in must have
been there that yeah that was probably
there because I I just I was shadowing
Tom around for years cuz I just wanted I
just wanted to be around when he was
teaching new people and then eventually
he about three years after we met he
proposed taking some of his protegees
I'm sure Andrew was in that conversation
over to India and training us to become
teachers and so I did that and after
that I started teaching people
meditation right that's crazy
Wow and now of course Charlie Knowles is
our mutual friend yet Tom's son exactly
well well-known meditate meditation
teacher and Tom is directly or
indirectly trained about 150 people in
the last 15 16 years yeah I mean for
those that are listening Tom Knowles is
one of the great legendary teachers in
meditation of all time of our generation
I should say yeah so cool so that was
the Vedic tradition right heretic
meditation yeah and since I had Bob here
yesterday perhaps
worth sort of discussing the differences
if there are any like what are the
differences between Vedic meditation and
TM so Tom used to be associated with the
Transcendental Meditation organization
and from what I understand a lot of
those teachers went independent in the
80s and 90s I think that was like a
political biosex I'm kind of yeah they
got involved they were right because
they were running a candidate for
president they were by the natural law
party yeah back in the 80s I think and
and I think a lot of the teachers
decided that that wasn't really what
they wanted to be a part of mm-hmm and
you know and then you know when you get
into politics the other politicians are
gonna start trying to paint you as you
know you're trying to take advantage of
people about and they started getting
all they start attracting all this
negative attention and I think they
started seeing a decline in their in
their in the number of people they were
teaching and then they needed to raise
more money so that's where they jacked
up the price is I mean this I don't know
firsthand yes there was a controversy
sure positive created a split yeah I
didn't really get into this with him but
but essentially at the end of the day
Vedic meditation and TM are essentially
the same thing and TM reached out to Tom
and said look you know you can't cause
Colin does this is a trademark right
only people who teach under our umbrella
can't call it Transcendental Meditation
so Tom said okay we'll call the vedic
min right gotcha gotcha right and that
kind of tracks back to I mean the root
of that really is that these traditions
if you want to differentiate them are
are really rooted in the importance of
the teacher-student relationship which I
think really distinguishes this
tradition or these traditions from other
forms of meditation that are a little
bit looser about that restriction or
that requirement it's like this this
reverence for how important that is and
in your own experience clearly this was
an important thing like you'd been
exposed of meditation you know for a
number of years until you actually have
formal instruction with the teacher and
that was really the the defining thing
that changed your life experience yeah
that's right I think one of the ways
that we talked about it is that you know
they're obviously going to be some
obstacles and some pitfalls in anyone's
meditation trajectory and being a
teacher and having been through that
path you kind of know where those
pitfalls are gonna be what the phases
are what the cycles are and you can help
help someone maintain a level of
self-sufficiency in their own practice
so that it can continue to be mobile and
accessible no matter where someone is no
matter what's around them they can still
sit down and drop into this this
meditative state as often as they as
they as they choose to so having a
teacher is really one of the more
invaluable aspects of this particular
approach to meditation but like I said
it's you know it's it's just one
approach all the approaches of
meditation are definitely taking the
practitioner in the same direction which
is towards accessing their their their
true self and if you have a teacher what
I've experienced is that the the road
tends to be a little bit easier right
now and but they would also are my
colleagues would also argue that you
can't learn how to meditate from a book
you can't get what you get from a
teacher in a book so it was an
interesting opportunity for me in
writing a book and just and and
presenting some of these mechanics and
and principles in such a way that
someone who doesn't necessarily have
contact with the teacher directly can
still glean some insight and hopefully
improve their experiences through what
they read in that book list more yeah
you you make it very clear in the book
like look you know there's no
replacement for the teacher and and you
know clearly you know I'm not trying to
replace that but here's a couple
guideposts you know to light your path
and and and you know as an introductory
kind of text for somebody should that
connect with them then they have the
opportunity at some point in the future
to you know explore the teacher-student
relationship a little bit more in depth
but when you were writing the book did
that was there like just the idea of
writing the book in and of itself
conceptually did that create some kind
of dissonance with you knowing how sac
sankt that teacher-student relationship
is like I know this this is what worked
for me and now I'm gonna write a book I
have just you know kind of at odds with
that yes absolutely absolutely I was
grappling with that the entire time I
still am to some extent it's hard to
separate what you know so intimately and
that's all I've been doing is
shepherding people through this process
for the last 11 years but at the same
time there's a level of frustration when
you overhear conversations about
meditation where people are basically
taking the symptom of of not knowing
what they're doing and making it into a
best practice mm-hmm for right well
there's no barrier to entry right you
know it's like touching you practice I
mean you can't you can't teach Vedic or
TM without being certified in a very
specific manner but anybody can call
themselves a meditation - that's right
just get up and pontificate so when
somebody when you overhear somebody
saying there's no wrong way to meditate
right like what is your well it's like
saying there's no wrong way to swim yeah
you know you sure you can get in there
and just kind of mess around but if you
want to be able you're not gonna say
you're I guess you're swimming if you
want to glide back and forth and do
kickturns and their practice their
mechanics that everyone who's and you
use that you use that analogy in the
book which I love because as a swimmer
myself like I know very well the
difference between somebody who really
understands how to swim yeah and
somebody who to the untrained eye kind
of looks like they're swimming but when
I look at them I'm like you're fighting
the water right whole principle was
swimming is trying to make the water
work for you and the way that I'm sorry
yeah exactly it's like this beautiful
symphony where everything all the
movements that you're making with your
body are in concert to make you go
forward and you have to like leverage
the principles of fluid dynamics to
propel yourself forward and you draw in
that analogy to like look this is the
same way it works with meditation rather
than fighting the mind it's about
finding a way to get the mind to work
with you so that you can create this
beautiful whoops
somebody's facetiming me right good what
is going on
I didn't even turn
my daughter sorry about that I was
making such a beautiful speech monologue
right there too but yeah the idea that
that that rather than you know this this
idea that I think a lot of people
mistakenly under mistakenly believe that
you have to kind of fight the fight the
impulses of the monkey mind yeah that
it's in fact the opposite of that yeah
and it's you know and you're not just
because you know that doesn't mean it's
gonna happen the first few times is like
swimming you know you have to practice
it and keep integrating those mechanics
over and over and then you end up being
able to do less and accomplish more do
least and accomplish most and ultimately
do nothing where it feels like I'm in
complete flow right now and you can swim
for however however long you swim and it
doesn't feel like this big effort where
it's wearing you out and you're gonna
drown and and so then someone like you
can look at a pool or a lake or ocean
and you just see joy mm-hmm whereas
someone like me when I was in my early
30s and I couldn't swim I would look at
the same body of water and just be
completely terrified and wondering how
deep is it and how cold is it and how
rough is it and you know because I knew
that once I got in if I didn't have an
exit strategy then there was gonna be
problems right that's how people feel
about meditation yeah and to extend that
metaphor even a little bit further when
I look at people in the pool now
specifically like triathletes they're so
focused on like getting fit like they
just they need to get their yardage in
like these and they got to knock that
workout out and they're just in there
battling the water and I'm like listen
you should just forget about your
fitness and go back to fundamentals like
if you just if I gave you these
principles to work on and you just
forgot about how fit you were and just
worked on your technique for three or
four months a year from now you'll be
ten times of the swimmer that that you
will be going down this path right so
it's like about mistaken
allocation of your priorities so to to
kind of further that example in the
context of meditation rather than like I
got to get my 20 minutes
and twice a day if you're doing it wrong
like okay let's step back and like let
me explain to you actually how to do
this properly so that you can leverage
the most out of it for your experience
so this is something that you you walk
through in the course of this book you
have this easy technique that you talk
about so maybe we can kind of dive into
that yeah the easy technique so you know
I've met a lot of people through the
meditation teaching and the scene and
literally thousands of people and not
one time has anyone ever shown some sort
of rejoice over having a busy mind that
once have a mind is so busy it's awesome
yeah that's never happened everybody
without exception complains that their
mind is too busy or you know monkey mine
and again that's the symptom that's not
the problem that's the symptom of the
real problem which is you have a monkey
body your body has been accumulating all
this stress not getting nearly enough
sleep probably not even probably a
malnourished and and when you sit down
to meditate three things are happening
number one you're going to start forming
this new relationship with your mind
right with your thoughts and probably
you had an antagonistic relationship
with your thoughts before so now you're
gonna have to kind of reframe that for
yourself so that's happening number two
your body under the influence of the
meditation is going to start achieving
profound states of rest and that's gonna
cause the body to start doing what
bodies do when they get rest which is
they rehabilitate themselves so the
rehabilitation of stress from the body
is going to create a degree of physical
activity physical activity is going to
cause your mind to be more active and
also it's going to cause you to have
thoughts and emotions and sensations and
experiences that may be related to old
past stress that is now leaving your
body mm-hmm now there are no scientific
studies that document that this is
exactly what's happening so you're gonna
have to go with gone go go on my word
with this but you know you hear this an
most every approach to meditation I was
listening to your Sharon Salzberg
interview and she was talking about you
know how meditational you people expect
to be happy and all that in meditation
and enough confronting their old demons
and things like that and that's another
kind of way of describing something that
is leaving you and as a result of that
once you come out of the meditation
later on you're no longer gonna have the
same intensity of triggers that you had
before you sat down to meditate so
that's happening and then the third
thing that's happening is that you're
breaking this old habit of not
meditating for however long you've not
been meditating which could for some
people be 30 40 50 years so then there's
a calcification that is said that's been
taking place where the brain fires and
wires in certain directions and if
you've only been experiencing surface
level mental activity and now the
meditation is taking you down into this
deeper level of awareness that is
creating the kind of soreness feeling
that you get when you work out after
having never worked out before so all
those things are kind of happening at
the same time and that's what causes
people to think I have a monkey mind but
really you don't have a monkey mind it
doesn't mean meditation wasn't working
any more than having sore muscles means
that oh I the gym didn't work yesterday
because my muscles are sore I can merely
sit now yeah and it can begin to reveal
to you the things that you need to work
on in your life which can be unpleasant
and painful it's sort of like people
that get sober and think well I solved
my problem and now life's gonna be
awesome but they overlook the fact that
they're then left with their emotions
without their best friend their best I'm
sorry you know they're they're reliable
tool for you know managing that and they
have to figure out a new healthier way
of you know grappling with you know
painful past trauma and the like and I
think it's similar like that you know
the way you describe it the way that it
brings to the surface all of these
things that you then have to confront
and create these new neural pathways and
it's super interesting I mean one of the
things that stuck out like in your book
you also have you said there's no
scientific studies on these specific
particular things but you have all these
kind of anecdotal stories of people who
have had these experiences and and one
of them that stuck out for me was the
woman who started smelling cigarette
smoke every time she was meditating even
though there was nobody smoking and she
had never smoked I mean you know explain
that because that was like is that real
like that's crazy ya know I taught this
woman to meditate she was in her mid
60's she described herself as a as a
health nut vegetarian yogi you know the
whole nine
she starts meditating and then she said
for the first couple of weeks all she's
smelling and tasting and experiencing in
her meditations it's this really intense
cigarettes sensation and it went on for
it lasted for a couple of weeks
literally every time she sat down to
meditate she would stop meditating and
open her eyes and then it would go away
she would close her eyes and it would
come back she went meditating in her car
because she wasn't sure if it was
something in about our house and she
said the same thing happened in her car
and she wasn't a smoker and so when she
told me about this I suspected what it
was but I wanted her to make the
connection so we started investigating I
started asking her questions have you
ever dated someone who smoked were you
married to someone who smoked did you
live around smokers no no no no no come
to find out when she was in her early
20s she was she had moved from Alabama
to New York City and she was there for a
few years and she had dabbled in smoking
but she said it couldn't be that because
that was 40 years ago mm-hmm and I've
been so healthy since then you know and
that's what the body is really good
about doing whenever it receives an
opportunity to rest at very deep levels
as it goes into the back of the closet
and it starts pulling out all stress and
triggers that have been living in there
for a very long time and it comes out
through the mind so the mind is sort of
like the exhaust pipe
it's the speaker of whatever's being
projected out as a result of the
meditation and the same thing happens
when we're sleeping at night you know
you go to sleep usually when people
start meditating in this way they report
having better sleep at night but they
also sometimes report having more vivid
dreams and sometimes even nightmares mmm
any time the body is resting deeply it
has a tendency to release and that
releasing is can wake the mine up and
when it gets woken up in the middle of
the sleep it it's experiencing a dream
and in the meditation you're
experiencing vivid thoughts or
sensations or emotions about things that
happen in the past that you haven't
thought about or experienced in a very
long time and I see this all the time I
mean I've been having these
conversations in living rooms for the
last 11 years thousands of people but
not very many people understand this and
the first place they go to when they
have the busy mind experiences there's
something wrong with my mind and they
start disqualifying themselves from
thinking that they can meditate when in
fact they're meditating perfectly that's
fascinating
you know it's it speaks to the the kind
of default human tendency to
compartmentalize unpleasant thoughts and
past experiences and we want to believe
when something like that happens that we
push it into the recesses of our
unconscious mind and we compartmentalize
it and we want to believe it didn't
happen or we're just we just want to
move on and we think it's we're done
with it right yeah and it's interesting
how I went through a class like like my
addiction it's like that the Tony
Robbins
I'm not your guru yeah helping people
like on the spot work through their
whole problem right is done and I'm
thinking I want to see what these people
are like in six months because if that
was the case why isn't everyone in AAA
going to the I mean I'm not taking
anything away from I'm sure Tony is very
powerful and the event is very powerful
but it just seems like that's at least
that's what they're portraying that this
is like an overnight thing and right
yeah it doesn't work that way who did I
have on I had a guy on who was talking
about tapping do you know about tapping
yeah and you know you do this technique
and then like you've either you're just
done with it
you know and it's like all right and
he's like all these people I've cured
them of all this thing and I was like
well and my life experience maybe
there's some temporary relief but
without some kind of diligent practice
to continue to you know kind of focus on
on keeping that at bay it's kind of
resurfaced that's right and that's why
you still exercise every day you know
and that's why people still meditate
even though
you know I've been meditating for 16
years in this particular technique and I
still do it every single day like
clockwork because stress isn't taken any
days off mm-hmm and insomnia you know
when people we all live busy lives I'm
traveling you're traveling and you get
sleep-deprived and jet-lagged here and
there and it's still you still have to
have these sort of these breaks right in
the nervous system in order to keep
functioning and it's never really about
getting to a place where you can rest on
your laurels it's all healed it's all
sorted out you know a lot of this is
just about going back to your earlier
point stabilizing a level of awareness
where you can make connections so that
when you are encountering problems in
your life you can have more clarity when
you're when you're coming up with the
solution you know so if you're sick or
you're experiencing cancer or something
like that and you start meditating
meditation isn't necessarily gonna heal
the cancer right it may but it's
probably it may not but you may have a
level of awareness that gives you the
better idea of what the course of action
is and you participating in your own
healing process empowering yourself and
these kinds of things so I really wanted
to humanize that practice and take it
out of the ethers right where people
very easily let themselves off the hook
it's not for me is for those people over
there and bring it down to the kitchen
table and show that you know while there
may be studies I know people who start
meted to who start smoking cigarettes
after they started meditating
I know people started drinking coffee
myself included after years after I
started meditating you know we're quick
to say oh I stopped drinking coffee and
I don't get anger you angry anymore this
and that yeah it's this panacea that's
just gonna solve all of it but that's
not that's not the reality of meditation
but it's also hard to describe that
reality if you've never tasted it for
yourself because it's still very
beautiful and profound and you get this
spaciousness inside that gives you
ability to step back when you when
otherwise you'd be very reactive and you
can't really put a price on those kinds
of experiences either you just have to
have the experience otherwise it's like
trying to tell someone what a watermelon
tastes like who's never even had fruit
before right there's no there's no
experiential context in order to really
evaluate that you know and this is what
this is something
that I talked about with Dan Harris as
well like the there is copious science
to support the fact that meditation is
going to lower your blood pressure and
reduce your anxiety and there's evidence
to suggest that it can combat depression
there are all these physiological
benefits as a result of it but it tends
to get overhyped right for the sake of
views and paid you know clicks and
things like that not eating sugar is
good for you not smoking cigarettes it's
very clear what the science says people
still wait because we we're addicted you
know no one's even talking about that as
a part of the equation you know a part
of what you're experiencing is you're
breaking down some of these addictions
and it's gonna be you know you may have
some of that come up in the practice
itself and so it's it's I think it's a
it's very very important for us to us as
as proponents of this kind of these
kinds of practices to be as as real as
possible when we're talking about it
because people may put me up on a
pedestal and think we'll light you know
you're you're light you know and and and
I can't be like light you're immune from
I can get in condition so that's why I
threw in a couple stories about my drama
that I've gone through and relationships
and stuff and that talked about how the
one important thing when you're
assessing how it's working for you so
you can never measure prevention you
don't know what you would have been
experiencing sure it got bad but it
could have gotten a lot worse if you
hadn't been meditating of course so at
the end of the day the question the only
question is in my opinion and as far as
what I've seen in this space is how hard
do you want to work because when things
tend to be challenging to execute we
don't do it when things feel easy we
love to do it you know no one has to
tell you to run
I follow you I follow your Instagram
sometimes they do
yeah but compared to any average that's
cuz your runs are like you know 25 miles
so you probably but that's the thing
like that you see that's my version of
of people projecting on to you that you
must be you know free of any dissent in
your relationship and you know you're
you live this anxiety stress free life
right because of the practice that you
do and the things that you teach people
do the same thing to me this
oh well you just you know you can just
go do all these things and it's
effortless for you that's not true you
know there's plenty of days where I wake
up and I don't feel like doing this or
that and and more often than not I do it
anyway and I share that but there are
times where I I don't you know I'm not
perfect in that regard yeah but there's
still you're still inclined to move your
body in some way whereas some other guy
diligent a caucus over decades right
pretty much gotten addicted to it at
this point
meaning if you don't work out something
in your body is gonna say rich you
should probably get up and go yeah for a
little swim today or something like that
or go eat some you know nut cheese or
something like yeah and and that's where
we need to get meditation we need to get
addicted to the biochemistry of the
practice which purely happens from
exposure
repeated exposure in order to get to
that point to some extent I think you
have to enjoy the practice and that's
that's my mission in the world is to
help people who sincerely want to
meditate learn how to enjoy it enough so
that they can be consistent enough so
that they can get the real benefits of
the practice because if you're only
doing it once a week I don't care what
study you read you're not gonna get
those been rights right yeah you have to
in order to connect with that addiction
this healthy addiction if you want to
call it that I mean has codependency
yeah it has such a pejorative yeah
dent to it but you have to first
confront and overcome your addiction to
your your identity for lack of a better
word like your attachment to the story
you tell yourself about yourself to you
know your default behavior patterns and
perspectives that are a preventing you
from even you know sort of embarking on
a meditation journey to begin with but
also are sending you those
self-defeating signals that you know
it's not going to work or you're not
worth it or whatever right so it becomes
about this journey to unpacking all of
that before you can even begin to avail
yourself of what you can receive by
virtue of this practice and that's what
I put in the breaking the old habit
category like all of those things you
just name are
part of that experience and that is to
be expected and you need to understand
that it's gonna happen and it's gonna
get intense because you know those those
old ways and those old neural patterns
and they're not they've been in there
for a very long time they're now they
don't plan on going away any time soon
because they're working to keep you safe
that's the that's the environment you've
basically told your body that you're
living in and so it's a survival it's
large part is a survival mechanism and
and it's it's made to shut down your
your broader perceptual ability where
you can step back and say oh no this is
just a you know this is a good for me or
that's not good for me you're not able
to make that sort of discernment and so
that's that's its job is to keep you
locked into the certain state so that
you can survive I told the story in the
book about this woman in my yoga class
who came to my class one night back when
I was teaching yoga and I played this
song over the rainbow and she jumped up
and she ran out of the room and she was
a lawyer and very well-read spiritually
and one of my regular students and I
didn't know why she ran out of the room
I just this was at the end of the class
so we only had 10 minutes left in the
class but she literally it was like she
saw a ghost she grabbed all of her stuff
in a haste and she just ran out of the
room and she came back a month later and
she came up to me I was killing up the
music at the beginning of the class and
she apologized she said I'm so sorry I
ran out of the room so abruptly the
other day but you played that song over
the rainbow you know over the over the
rainbow by the Hawaiian guy beautiful
song and she told me the back story the
back story was earlier that morning of
the class she had had a run-in with her
husband and apparently she found some
receipt look like he had been possibly
cheating on her she wasn't sure but
there was it created this big argument
and confusion and she was processing all
day long and she decided she was gonna
go to the class to try to cool off and
wind down and and she said over the
rainbow was their wedding song
okay Dennis as soon as I played their
wedding song she said I don't know what
came over me I just had to get out of
the class so could you please not play
that song again and when she told me the
back story knowing what I knew about
meditation and stress and everything
made sense you know because when you're
being triggered in that way and that's
become a big buzzword nowadays trigger
mm-hmm when you're triggered what's
really happening is everything in your
body is telling you you're being
attacked and in her case the the bear or
the tiger or whatever the attacker was
was that song mmm no really it was tied
to her husband and everything associated
with him as a result of whatever they
experienced that morning a song that
previously was a very beautiful nice
memory
now conjured up the memory of danger and
it's a song about butterflies and
lullabies and Blue Jays but the part of
the brain that gives her the ability to
see that connection that this is just a
two-minute song I'm in a yoga class
nothing bad is happening it gets shut
down and everything inside of her says
you have two options you can run away as
quickly as possible or you can fight and
she chose to run away and that's it
that's how you know you're under the
influence of of the stress and so when
we talk about you know meditation
releasing this stuff if she started
sitting down and meditating she may
spend the first three or four
meditations thinking about crazy
thoughts related to her husband or crazy
thoughts related to her marriage or you
know how much she wants to get a divorce
or you know how she doesn't like being
single not realizing that that
represents the stress that was already
inside of her because that's what locked
it up in the first place it was inside
of her already now it's leaving and now
she's being liberated from her past so
how do you know the meditation is
working not based on the fact that
you're having thoughts about some crazy
thing related to your husband can you
hear that song again and stay in the
room mm-hmm that's how you know it's
working
mm-hmm and so measuring progress needs
to be properly understood as well
because I think people are missing the
gold in it because they're they're too
fixated on the prot the the whatever's
coming out of the exhaust pipe right
and that's an extreme example but it
makes me think about how much we're all
impulse on a lower level throughout our
daily experience by stimuli that we're
not even consciously aware is you know
triggering months of Towson yes yeah
well your normal won't even know yeah
look at that that's activating something
inside of us that's getting us to be
reactive or aggressive or irritable and
we don't even know what's happening and
most of them are from childhood mm-hmm
so you know we're very much a slave to
our stress and the stress dictates how
well we sleep at night it dictates how
effectively we communicate it dictates
how adaptable we are how generous we are
a compassionate we are because we all
want these things you know you read The
Four Agreements you think okay fantastic
I'm gonna start never taking anything
personally and always being impeccable
and this and that and what's the first
thing that goes out the window
when you know someone cuts you off or
you leave your podcast equipment back
yeah all control goes goes out the
window and I think when you say it goes
back to childhood it's important to
point out for somebody who's listening
it doesn't imply that you were abused as
a child or that you had some sort of
terrible experience as a kid like this
is something I've wrestled with because
I had a normal childhood like I can't
think of any specific you know extreme
trauma that I suffered from but I had
pains like things no matter who you are
like throughout your childhood you're
going to suffer from one time or another
and because of the plasticity of your
your mind and your life experience at
that point those things get cemented
right it's not fully developed you're
not socially mature enough to deal with
rejection abandonment things these
things like I got lost one time in the
mall with my mom I was eight years old
and to me I was I might as well have
been left in Afghanistan and she was in
America today we're still talking about
it
right yeah but obviously now looking
back she's probably one store over but
to me it felt like you know I lost her
forever
and so and and a lot of times people are
still coping with abandonment or loss or
breakups or getting fired in the same
way that they were dealing with it when
they were seven eight years old
which qualifies as an over reaction
which means that those same brain
connections that led to you feeling like
you were lost forever when you're eight
are now being hardwired still when
you're twenty eight or thirty eight or
forty eight which means that you know
you end up overreacting or mal adapting
to that change as it occurs to you when
you're an adult and not able to tap into
in a more mature way of deal right like
so when your part when you call your
partner and you really need to talk to
that person and they're like I can't
talk right now and they like hang up
your that ball yeah call me bad abandon
again that's right now and you're gonna
have an extreme reaction to that's right
mmm-hmm that's right that's usually
where extreme reactions that's why when
you go to therapy which is great at well
you know I think therapy is a great
thing but we end up talking about what
happened when we were children for a lot
of the time right and how it's still
playing out in all of our relationships
and that just means the stress triggers
are still very active in your body and
so what meditation does probably more
effectively than most other
interventions is it can neutralize those
triggers you don't forget what happened
you don't even forget how you felt when
it happened but it no longer dictates
how you react today and that's that's
the measure of of you know is this
meditation working or not right even if
it just gives you that extra moment of
pause before you you're and then you
catch yourself and you're like oh I have
a choice here yeah I can respond
differently and that white space even if
it's a nanosecond can make the
difference between ending up in a huge
fight with your spouse or just defusing
the entire thing and sometimes you know
you may still have depression you may
still have other kinds of disorders even
though you've been meditating for 10 or
15 years and that could be there could
be a higher purpose to that you know you
have a if you're a guy like a Dan Harris
or somebody who's like you know got a
big platform and and he's born I love
about Dan is he's so relatable Rio and
people see him and they think oh he can
do it I can do it you know and people
see someone like me and they hear about
my name and all that and they may not
necessarily relate to me as much so I
love it when people come up to me and
they say
meditating for five six years and I'm
still grappling with this thing and I
say well that's that's just because you
know nature needs you to be more
relatable right and people are gonna
come to this practice because they can
identify with what you're going through
and they can also probably recognize
that spaciousness within you more than
you recognize it within yourself and I
tell this other story in the book about
this woman that I taught this lawyer who
got into a big fight with her husband
this is after coming in and and
complaining to me after a year of
meditating nothing it's nothing was
happening and so now she's at dinner
three months later with her husband
they're having this huge argument
apparently this was their pattern having
these huge arguments she said I was
right he was wrong the usual and and
then she said okay after the argument
was dead and buried she kept eating and
he started looking at her like she was a
ghost and then finally she couldn't take
any more she goes why are you staring at
me like that
he said because six months ago you would
have left me in the restaurant after an
argument like that that's what we do we
argue you leave mm-hmm but you're just
able to just let it go
yeah he said I think that meditation is
working yeah yeah yeah and so to her on
the surface it felt like it's not
working because she still had the fight
her response and her ability to get over
it yeah you know it's like the half-life
of the negative emotions because we
don't realize how deeply rooted some of
this stuff is and it may take a thousand
meditations in a row before it's finally
liberated and and you know a year and
meditations nothing has you right as a
lot of long-term meditators experience
that years nothing you know ten years is
really not that much and we're talking
about major progress I mean progress is
is incremental but it's steady provided
that your practice is steady mm-hmm one
of the things that I struggle with
despite having you know hours and hours
of conversations with people like
yourself I'm completely sold on the
benefits of this and I've experienced
the benefits myself but I still struggle
with cancer with a consistent practice
like I can't say that I do it every
single day certainly not twice a day
sustainability you know I know in my own
life experience with anything on earth
succeeded at sustainability is the most
important quality
you know bar none when it comes to
trying to advance yourself in any
practice or pursuit and I still I still
continue to like struggle with
prioritizing this yeah so I would
imagine this is something that you come
up against with the students that you
teach you know how do you wrap your head
around getting people to understand the
importance of the sustainable aspect of
doing it consistently well the I
subtitle my book how to succeed in
meditation Without Really Trying and I
know some people may think you know
using success in the same sentence with
meditation is is is a you know you
shouldn't do that and the word in the
book the way I define success very
specifically is meditating in a way that
you enjoy and look forward to doing
because that's really the only way
you're going to maintain the consistency
that's necessary as if you look forward
to doing it and I there's it's no
exaggeration to say that I wake up in
the morning and I can't wait to meditate
and when I'm meditating I don't want to
stop I have oftentimes have to stop
because I just you know I have stuff to
do but I would just keep going over I
just I can't wait in the afternoon and
meditate again and there's nothing
special about me I don't
I wasn't born I wasn't at from Alabama I
wasn't born you know enlightened or it
wasn't born with his knowledge I just
learned mechanics and those mechanics
weren't very complicated you know in the
same way that for someone who has two
arms and two legs and you've learned how
to swim it's not complicated but if
someone says you know swimming is too
hard you may think yourself well you
just don't understand it well enough yet
you know you just need to learn how to
do it and then it will work for you and
so I think the same thing is true for
meditation in that when people
understand certain mechanics and what
the mechanics I'm talking about really
are very simple like body position
there's this idea that in order for
meditation to be most effective you have
to sit up straight and you have to cross
your legs that hasn't been my experience
you know I was taught the first day I
met my teacher you should actually
sit like you're watching television and
that frees up your mind to get lost in
an experience right and the way you you
interact with your mind you know you
focus on this focus on that visualize
this that wasn't my experience I was
taught you let your mind roam free and
that's getting back to the easy approach
easy as an acronym for how you think how
you handle your your mental and
sensational experiences East Anne's for
embrace a stands for accept s for
surrender why and yield to so what are
you embracing accepting surrendering to
and yielding to all of your mental
emotional even physical experiences
during the meditation so if you have an
itch you scratch it if you get
uncomfortable you switch your position
so that you remain comfortable if you
have thoughts about work that's amazing
it's not just I'm just gonna accept it
no no you look at it you celebrate it
this is amazing it's the best thing that
could be happening right now
is me thinking about this work problem
or me thinking about how I don't like
myself right that goes back to that that
overcoming this urge or this idea that
you have to combat the monkey mind right
you stop sucking at it as a monkey mind
you start looking at it as a noble mind
the mind is it's like taking it's like
if your radio station was tuned into a
music you don't like you take the
speaker and you throw it against a wall
because you don't like it's not the
speaker the speaker's is projecting
what's coming out of the channel and
when the mind is just projecting what's
coming out of the body it's not a bad
mind it's just showing you what's
leaving the body so it requires a
complete reframing of the experience
which over time is going to allow the
practitioner to start to have a
completely different relationship with
their mind and then that's going to
create a little bit of space in the
meditation which allows you to sit there
and enjoy it more and more and then the
irony of all of this is that when you
are seeing your mind as an ally and not
the enemy of the practice that place you
want to go to the place where everybody
wants to go to the calmness the
quietness the deepness that's where you
go mmm that it's it's literally how long
is it going to take I've seen how can I
I've said I get there quick I've seen
people get there and literally within an
hour really practicing absolutely yeah I
mean this is I want to make a disclaimer
this is working with me one on one and
that's when I'm suggesting anyone needs
to do but I did the very best I could to
put those principles in this book so
that you know if you are taken seriously
enough and you follow the instructions
as written then you're gonna have that
experience pretty quickly and I we
started doing this 21-day challenge
which is a companion to the book and
people have been after for days people
have been reporting having that same
experience it's not complicated that's
the thing I feel almost guilty walking
around knowing that I've been having
these wonderful we want to
overcomplicate it though right you know
I think it's human beings we're like
okay like you taught me that but like
take me behind the velvet rope like now
tell me the real thing like it's like in
in in recovery when people are
struggling or they're they're dealing
with some uncomfortable emotion the
answer is always the same it's like are
you working with newcomers or you go
into meetings where are you with the
steps like like have you have you
reached out to help somebody else like
and it's like come on bad again like
there's got to be another like there's
got to be another solution for my super
complicated unique problem that you
can't understand same with swimming man
you know there's no way to have you just
got to practice it you've got to take
the techniques and practice practice
those techniques over and over and then
before you know it was gonna click and
you'll be having a wonderful time but
one of the things that we don't talk
about a lot in meditation I wanted to
talk about this is the idea of the
exchange you know you mentioned that it
was too expensive when you first came
and obviously a lot of people feel like
that and some people even feel you
shouldn't charge anything to learn how
to teach someone to meditate and that
kind of thing but what you do see as a
teacher is that having some sort of
energetic or meaningful exchange doesn't
have any money could be anything it
definitely translates to having a deeper
relationship and you know when it comes
to
you waking up and not feeling like
meditating one day even though it's a
great thing to do just remind
remembering oh that's right I made that
change yeah I'm gonna sit down and do
this thing we get my money's worth out
of it and so it does it affects it
affects things in a really nice way and
and I talked about that in the book as
well and that's one of the ways I kind
of I came to terms with the dissonance
that you were saying earlier about
putting all this in a book is I also
include it what I consider to be
probably one of the most important
elements in the in the technique which
is which has nothing to do with actually
sitting out in meditating and everything
to do with sacrificing something you
know I was telling a friend of mine the
other day about these what I wanted my
life to become in 2018 and 19 and she
asked me a really profound question she
says what are you willing to give up
because you can't be an author as you
know and watch all the Netflix shows you
know you have to sacrifice time and
things you would rather probably be
doing to sit down by yourself and write
and or go run or you know everything
requires a sacrifice and if you look at
all meditation styles they're all
there's a sacrificial element to all of
it except when people learn from a book
or you know go online and do a YouTube
video or something like that you're
sacrificing your the five minutes you're
watching the video but there needs to be
some sort of bigger sacrifice and this
is what you see when you go to India
people will give up their whole lives to
go and study with them a master of
something like this and no one's ever
really mastered meditation without
having some sort of intimate
relationship with a practice and that
intimacy does not happen intellectually
it happens it happens through you kind
of opening up yourself
in a way that humbles you to what you're
about to receive right which is to say
you're you're when you give a sacrifice
of something it could be time could be
money could be gifts could be mentoring
someone when you when you put yourself
in that position you're basically saying
I don't know everything there is to know
about everything what
I knew got me to the point where I'm now
seeking out some other help and even
though we don't have a great
appreciation for this in the West
because again there's no scientific
studies that demonstrate the power of
this but it in the east they look at it
as it's opening up your consciousness to
receive the knowledge that already
exists and it's now coming into you and
through you and it's not yours as though
you own it it's just it's now channeling
through you and it allows you to have
better experiences deeper experiences
and in that more profound relationship
with your practice that's interesting I
never have thought of it in such
specific terms but it's definitely true
you know it's definitely true that if
you just are given something for free
you're not going to be emotionally
invested in it and the chances of it's
sticking are not going to be that high
right but when you have sacrificed
yourself in any way it doesn't have to
be financial then you're creating that
you're creating that emotional
investment in in the long term kind of
viability of whatever it is you're
seeking even going to the pastina
retreat which you know they bill is a
free retreat you're still spending ten
days yeah it's a sit you're not working
that's big that's more than paying the
thousand dollars mm-hmm you know
depending on what you do for a living
and and then they hit you up for a
donation at the end of it so then
there's that kind of obligation that
energetic obligation I should give
something because I did you know it gave
me food and you know you know how we are
and so you know people will say well I
do the pasta that's free that's not free
actually and and if if you're not
willing to sacrifice something then
you're not willing to be a student right
because you're basically now dictating
to the teacher you know more than they
know and this is how this is how it's
gonna happen mm-hmm and no teacher worth
their salt is gonna want to teach
someone like that you want to teach
someone who you know it's gonna follow
the instructions and they're gonna have
at least enough consistency to get
through the baseline instruction so that
you can have a foundation for your
practice what would you say is the
biggest benefit that you've experienced
from meditation I would say it's first
of all I want to just click qualify this
it's hard for me to know
well you don't yeah you'd have to see
yourself in another dimension a
different life I guess in this case that
like you I had a really good childhood
you know it's funny I was being
interviewed last night and this woman
was saying what's the biggest challenge
you've had to overcome and this is
someone who experienced genocide in
Rwanda who was asking me this question
so them automatically thinking oh boy I
haven't had any real problems yes
actually
I didn't see my whole family get
executed and you know and I was only
five years old and and that kind of
thing and there's you know sometimes
there's there can be a little bit of
shame around you know in this
vulnerability obsessed culture about not
having not having more dramatic
experiences in the kind of health and
wellness and in a quote unquote like
inspirational space like it's this thing
like you have to tell everyone this
horrible thing that happened how you
overcame all of that kind of stuff and I
think a lot of that gets trumped up and
it's supposed to say oh if I you yet to
be an expert in this thing and it's like
well you know I I do agree that we're
all we all experience challenges in our
own way like I could say I could make
the argument that as an african-american
growing up in America that's challenging
you know in ways that people who aren't
african-american will never quite
understand but to answer your question I
didn't feel like I was a big stressed
out you know anxiety ridden you know
person before I started meditating you
had this huge crisis that's right that
you had I was really curious and for
whatever good fortune I was I had always
had a healthy relationship with my
intuition my intuition would say quit
that job no one's happy there and I
listen to it I just quit the job my
intuition says travel to this
destination one way you don't know
anyone I would just and once you start
doing that kind of thing over and over
you start to become callous to the
resistance that inevitably will try to
persuade you to stay in the status quo
and so when I came across meditation it
was another thing that said I mean when
Tom told me you know the exchange for
this instruction is a week's salary
you'd get to determine what that is for
yourself I don't need to see your tax
returns
or anything like that I saw that as an
amazing opportunity I don't know why but
I just did I just thought and I wasn't
making any money at the time I was
teaching about you know four or five
yoga classes mostly for free or for very
little money but I said you know what I
have an opportunity here to dictate how
much I want to make and so I know by an
out by putting giving this amount it was
like four hundred dollars or something
like that that was half my net worth at
the time I probably had eight hundred
dollars in the bank account
then I that's a big you know knowing
about the law of attraction before the
law the secret came out and all of that
I just felt like I was triggering
something very powerful and so I did
that and that's how I started it and I
tell people all the time the way you
start anything you know it was gonna
dictate how that relationship unfolds
and you have a very powerful opportunity
to either and this is with anything
whether I don't care what it is you know
if I'm joining a running club if I'm
gonna start crocheting or something the
way you invest in it in the very
beginning you can determine that for
yourself you have an opportunity to
determine that for yourself if you don't
determine it if you feel like okay I'm
on it
I'm gonna get more than I leave behind
then it gets determined for you later in
some way mm-hmm and that's usually not
it doesn't feel like a very positive
thing because someone else is kind of
giving you the cost and just a practical
situation is you know you have something
your heart really wants to do you don't
do it and it was gonna cost you $800
that you had but you just didn't want to
spend it and then later on your car
breaks down and guess how much it cost
to fix $800 is there a connection I
don't know but I've had a lot of
experiences where it's uncanny
how I'll bypass something that I feel in
my heart I should be doing because I
just I'm being a cheapskate and and then
later on down the line I'm blowing in on
something completely unrelated right and
so you know the way we start these
practices is going to dictate how how
the thing unfolds and we can end up
creating for ourselves very very
powerful experiences
and so with me with meditation my
powerful experience it was having a
level of clarity that I don't think I
would have and having the still small
voice inside turn into a loud annoying
voice
right and so that intuition which we all
have it's very quiet and so we miss it a
lot of the time or we second-guess it or
we think ah you know the ego voice is
very much louder but when you meditate
meditate meditate the voice gets louder
and louder and louder and then you just
can't ignore it I think I think a lot of
people's intuition is compromised though
because it's impulse by reactivity or
address all these stresses like the
Trojan horse and your computer that gets
in there yeah yeah it's like it has a
virus you know and it's it becomes
untrustworthy and when people rely upon
it it leads them astray because they
don't have that clarity yeah and they
don't know it's just my body talking to
me telling me to go get Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts or just my intuition yeah yes
I need this is telling me that I need
that you need to clarify and that's why
I say meditation is like a spam filter
for your mind if you didn't have a spam
filter on your email it's gonna take you
forever to go through and sort through
all the viagra emails and the inkjet
emails and the guy in Nigeria who wants
money can't get to the important stuff
and so when you filter that out you
don't have to deal with that nonsense
and that's what that's what I would say
it's done for me and says allowed me to
rise above the nonsense so you know you
get trolled and when you're a public
figure and you're putting work out into
the public people are gonna criticize
you they're gonna troll you they're
gonna say you know this and that about
you and I don't I I would imagine this
is from my meditation but it doesn't it
doesn't really affect me
I don't personalize these things anymore
in the way that I used to and miss sleep
because right I'm sitting here thinking
after you gave me the big speech about
how you made the decision to take the
class for Tom I'm thinking and I guess I
should have done that I was like I
wonder what would have happened if like
light was in my shoes and said now I
can't afford it and I was the one who
like said I'm gonna do this like if like
our lives could you know be potentially
very different right now we could also
make the argument that it was MIT this
is the intersection that was supposed to
make maybe a different journeys towards
this moment that's where I get to sit
down and talk to
but and then the listener wouldn't have
the benefit of the colorfull had you not
had that experience and and my intuition
is telling me alright well I've had two
guys in a row on the podcast talking
about Vedic meditation like what is the
universe trying to say to me yeah I
would be happy to show you everything I
know
rich because four days you dangle this
carrot in front of me right now
do you think about like do you consider
yourself to have a role in the in the in
the conversation around the lower
socioeconomic class being
african-american like do you you know
how because they aren't that nor Kippy
that many african-american meditation
teachers right do you think about that
or do you just have not any others that
teach in the way that I teach yeah
that's something that I think we
definitely need more of but that was
again it was a big motivation for me in
in that a lot of people who grew up in
the way that I grew up and who don't
have access to these kind of this kind
of knowledge I wanted to I wanted to
change the conversation and I wanted to
get that in in their hands and scale the
knowledge as much as possible without
without sacrificing the quality of the
knowledge and I don't think it may not
happen in in my lifetime to the extent
that I would love for it to happen but
you know it's got to start somewhere and
and hopefully you know young black kids
look at me and and think to themselves
well he can you know he can be a
meditation teacher I can be a meditation
teacher or I should start meditating
like him and and really what I want to
do is I want to get this into the pop
culture a little bit more because that's
really where you know they give that
trickle-down effect and and and in the
black community you know when when jay-z
starts talking about meditation and
Kanye and Drake and these guys then I
think that's where it's gonna really hit
critical mass for us mm-hmm well I think
it's happening you know it isn't process
more quickly but Jay Cole is a meditator
you know there are a lot of guys like
that who I think maybe Bob Roth taught
some of these guys yeah I think you
senator
right he's a meditator what's next for
you you're going to New York right are
you doing let's talk about the shine a
little bit yeah right so you know the
shine is one of the big reasons I think
why some of the publishers were looking
at me as the person to write this book
and the shine is a nonprofit that I
started a few years ago in Los Angeles
as a means of introducing people to the
practices like meditation around other
things that they're already excited
about which is you know TED talk like
experiences live music and then it was
also an outlet for me because I stopped
drinking for the most part in my mid-20s
and you know as you know it changes the
social dynamic a little bit and and you
know I still like having fun and going
out and but I don't really enjoy being
around a lot of people who are tipsy and
you know having those kinds of
conversations so I wanted to create an
environment where people who had saved
the same sort of sensitivities and
interests could come together on a
Friday night or Saturday night have a
great time but also have a natural high
instead of an artificial high and so we
started every event with meditation then
that leads us into some story where we
listen to someone who's a real person
you spoken at the shine before get up
and tell their story of how they what
their hero's journey has been and how
they're out there helping people you
know helping spread positivity in the
world and and so it's been it's been
going really well and we've done you
know probably close to 100 events at
this point we're in New York or in
London now it's gotten to the point
where there was an event that I wasn't
at which was my first one not being
there that happened in London last week
and so that's a exciting sign at the
time
sign of the times because it forces me
to have to let go a little bit and just
kind of let it yeah let it fly so you
think it's gonna fly and so you know
that's cool so you start how long you
already started four or five years ago I
started in in June of 2005
2014 mm-hmm it's a pretty special thing
I mean for people that are listening
it's sort of like a large dinner party
meets meditation class with like a TED
talk sort of you know inspirational
story but there's food and there's fun
and the the my experience is that the
people that attend are all like soup
everybody you meet is like doing
something cool and like everybody's
super engaged and interesting and the
fact that there isn't alcohol like it it
sort of attracts a certain type of
person who's looking for a more
uplifting type of experience on a Friday
or Saturday night as opposed to going to
the bar that's righti and they're just
there's something really unique and cool
about the environment that you create
with these events it's really cool and
one of the best parts of the experience
I think is when we you know we we charge
30 bucks which and all the money goes to
pay for the venue and you know the cost
of food and that kind of thing and then
we take we try to budget it so there's
about 400 dollars left over and we give
it to someone we that we randomly select
in the audience and we we tell them to
go out and spend it in any way that
inspires them to help other people and
we've collected so many stories and
videos and they come back and they share
how they saw they they did with it yeah
right which is it it's amazing what you
can do with $400 and you know the idea
behind it was we wanted to inspire other
people who aren't you know millionaires
and billionaires that you can you can
make a difference you don't have to wait
until you write you hit it big to be
able to be philanthropic you can take
whatever you can take $200 and go out
and do something that can change
someone's life and that's how that's how
change is gonna happen is from every one
of us you know being the change we want
to see yeah when I was in my 20s living
in New York City there was nothing like
that but you're seeing like I don't know
whether it's just the millennial
generation but in influx of events like
the shine absolutely popping up whether
it's wanderlust or Daybreaker where you
get quiet and you're dancing at seven
o'clock in the morning like all these
sorts of things that are that are
becoming you know part of like means
dream culture like oh let's go do this
like alternatives to the traditional
let's go to the bar and get hammered
right yeah it's an exciting time to be
in this space because I think it's still
very much being formulated and in it I
don't think people in you know in a lot
of parts of Middle America or maybe even
around the world are having these
conversations yet but I think it's
coming and what's happening here in LA I
think it's going to be it's kind of be
making a very big impact and what's
going to be happening throughout the
rest of the country and in the coming 10
or 15 years when you look around right
now
you know clearly we're in a very
divisive critical moment in our culture
tempers are running hot and you know
there's a divisive nnessee n-- in my
lifetime so are you somebody who who is
optimistic about the future like how do
you kind of process current events and I
think we're seeing you know the pendulum
swing from one direction to the other I
mean you can make the argument that if
if there was no Barack Obama we wouldn't
be in the situation we're in right now
but if there wasn't a President Bush we
wouldn't be in the Barack we wouldn't
have had the Barack Obama situation so I
just think this is a natural reflection
of the shifting that takes that natural
that just takes place in general it's
gonna swing back any other direction but
you know the great thing about is that
it's creating these kinds of
conversations you know you're probably
getting more podcasts nowadays than ever
before you're getting more people
talking about sexual harassment racism
put more people learning about politics
I've a friend the other day just
announced he's gonna run for Congress I
mean you know these things wouldn't be
happening to the extent they're
happening if they weren't getting so
crazy on the other end and I think this
is a beautiful catalyst for that and I'm
not saying we should accept it but we
should do what we can do to make the
situation better mm-hmm
and that this is death that's the call
this is a dog whistle for everybody to
listen to what's in their heart and
start taking action because there's not
enough you know Einstein s is wonderful
or no mark twain has this wonderful
quote the two most important days of
your life the day you're born
and the day you figure out why and I
would argue that there's a third most
important day which is the day you take
action on your why you know it's not
enough just to know what your why is you
got to take some steps into that
direction so that we are not depriving
the world anymore of the gift that
you're here to bestow and I would
imagine you would say to that to the
question that most people don't know
there why that if you're struggling with
what your why is meditation you sort
that out I think that is that is true I
think most people don't know their why
and part of that is because they are
living their life reflexively and
reactively and externally yeah yeah
there's got to be some internal
experiences in order to really truly
feel your intuition you have to feel it
because just even knowing it is not
enough you have to feel that you're
going to be safe if you move in that
direction and the interesting thing
about it and they've been talking about
this in wisdom traditions for a very
long time but moving in the direction of
your interview and your intuition is
going to take you to a layer a layer of
uncertainty all right we are obsessed
with control and certainty so moving
towards uncertainty is usually the last
place we want to go we'd rather stay or
does the better the devil you know we'd
rather stay in the status quo even
though it's not great because we're
familiar with it then move towards the
unknown but if you want to thrive if you
really want to live your Dharma you have
to move in the direction of the unknown
and that's how you know what your
intuition talking to you so you need to
feel that because when you feel it in
every core of your being you won't be
able to ignore it anymore and that's
that's what I how I've identified my
Lane I'm not gonna be the guy out there
you know with the picket signs on the
front line but I'll help you tap into
that place inside where you may be the
one running for president or you know
pushing this new initiative through
Congress or inspiring a generation of
women to stand up for themselves and you
know all of these things and and you
know there's no such thing as the happy
serial killer so happy people
they typically do things that are
creative that are inspirational and that
reflect the level of leadership that I
think is very attractive and I think
that's what the world needs more off
beautifully set when you think about
happiness how do you define that for
yourself I define happiness as having a
state of fulfillment and contentedness
and what you and where you are and what
you're doing so that means in any moment
whether you're in stuck in traffic
locked in an elevator you know and I'm
picking very extreme situations in the
post office in a long line there's a
there's a level of contentedness you may
not like it where you are but you know
that you're right where you're supposed
to be and if you stay if you see if you
kind of dance with that knowingness that
you're right where you're supposed to be
it leaves you open to spotting whatever
available opportunities are present if
you are operating under the assumption
that you're supposed to be over there
but you're over here and this thing that
you're experiencing is a big obstacle
keeping you from getting to your true
path then you're gonna miss those
opportunities and the opportunities that
you need in order to stay on your path
are only gonna be available to you in
that present moment right so that's what
people you know that when we say we're
in flow that's what in my interpretation
that's what that means is that you're
you're hopping from one opportunity to
the next to the next to the next
you're not seeing anything as an
obstacle you're seeing everything as a
gateway to the next opportunity and so
that's that encapsulates my idea of
happiness because you're no longer
wishing you were somewhere other than
where you currently right stop resisting
what is to some extent yet right and
being present for what is right in front
of you to experience is the it's the
only it's the only path yeah but you
know I would even say you know because I
don't want people let themselves off the
hook resistance resistance can be there
we can you can resist all you want but
as long as you know that within that
resistance you're still on the path you
know and so if the resistance is there
40% you need to have your
your intuition your clarity and those
perceptual acuity powers they're 50% if
it's just a little bit higher than the
resistance then you can still you can
still make your way it's great if the
resistance isn't there at all that's
that's you know best best-case scenario
but that's not reality even for me I
have resistance you know when I released
this book I want the book to do what I
wanted to sell I want to go on all the
podcasts I want to you know feel like
everyone's talking about this book but
that's not the reality of the situation
so if I'm gonna wake up every day and be
excited about this path that I'm finding
my cell phone I need to understand that
part of that reality is nobody really
cares except for a very small
except for a very small group of people
care life and you still have to you know
if you you have to take your cues from
from your heart mm-hmm not from being
validated by society yeah because if
you're not you're not gonna get that
most of the time and you're gonna
interpret that you'll be looking it
won't satisfy me so you're looking for
well but that guy hasn't yet given me
the eventually and how did they get a
best-seller and I I'm you know so if
that's your if that's what you're
relying on it's a really crazy roller
coaster ride and and you know I've done
enough of that and I just like to keep
reflecting becoming more and more self
referral so I can stay true to my path
and if my path happens to lead to this
or that or wherever it goes
perfect that's and you know you can't
practice that inside and this is what I
talk about in the easy technique you put
that that's essentially what you're
practicing is you're reframing the
mental experience and if you do that
enough times it's not possible for it
not to carry over into your external
experience instant but if you find
yourself in the clutches of a reactive
moment like that or an unhealthy
attachment or an extreme emotional
reaction you know how do you break that
like I guess with practice with
meditation you suddenly have an inkling
of an awareness where you can go oh wait
and then you can step outside of it well
I mean that's where having a teacher
really comes in handy because you can go
and you can say to your teacher hey look
I'm feeling like I'm backsliding
and your teacher who's gonna be able to
see the whole picture you know it's
gonna say well you're still moving
forward you know just remind you rien
spire you and all of the things that
teachers do and you still may have to go
through that a little bit longer but now
you have some assurance from someone
who's been there before you just to
remind you of what's actually happening
and that's that can really that's really
the big value of having a teacher
because otherwise in order to reconcile
you'll be very a very strong person and
you have to have a lot of experiences to
be able to see that the next thing you
hop to was the better you ended up in a
better place than you imagined for
yourself so I think a lot of people tend
to give up in the process of of facing
that resistance and you know go in the
other direction towards what we think is
safety because it's what we're familiar
with but even within that you're still
you can't you can't devolve this isn't
you only you're only ever evolving but
you're your resistance just creates the
feeling of swimming upstream but the
stream is still it's still you know
causing you to float down you're just
not pulling down as quickly as maybe you
could if you just relax a little bit and
just let it let it take you where it's
going right
it's that relaxation that that that
release I think that's so
counterintuitive because we want to just
we want to will it to happen right we we
believe that the exertion of force or
some kind of purposeful and you know
kind of aggressive intentionality is the
solution whereas it's quite the opposite
right one of the most beautiful quotes
I've seen comes from conversations with
God Neale Donald Walsch and I can't
remember his guy talking or him asking a
question but someone says in the book
you can relax to the extent that you
trust in life I just love that mmm
there's a law section about yeah if your
anchors in tents you're probably not
trusting that something is happening for
your highest and best good and you're
under the delusion that you have control
have got so many things that you have no
control over right so yeah I would say
meditation just kind of helps you become
more friendly with the unknown and
and comfortable with not being in
control not not giving yourself the
illusion that you're in control and just
being actually kind of excited about not
being in control of anything and seeing
where this thing is taking me let me
imagine that imagine you woke up every
day you don't know what the hell is
gonna happen terrifying this is amazing
you know yeah I mean you have to I mean
I've had some amazing experience
oberyn's always surrender until I really
you know reckoned with that delusion of
control you know that's what kept me in
the grips of a lot of unhealthy
behaviors and you know I don't do it
perfectly but there's a there's such a
relief when you can like release that mm
and realize like you don't have to be
holding on like that and in fact it's
preventing you from moving forward in
the best way possible right and and I
think you know as a long-term meditator
what you experience is it's a gradual
gradual transition into that where you
don't even realize how much you're okay
with not being in control until
something big happens you have a big
loss or some big stark change and then
someone else says to you you know like
that lawyer client of mine oh my god the
way you handled that was just amazing
yeah because you can't see the growth in
yourself it has to be reflected back to
you through others cuz the other the
other option is you try to force it you
try to like you know okay I'm going to
accept this because I listen to some
positive thought CD and I'm gonna now
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna be positive
all the time white-knuckling though but
your intellectual still trying to
control it that's right and inside it
there's still that friction and it's
it's it's it's unattractive people can
kind of read that and in you if it's not
authentic if it's not coming from an
authentic place mm-hmm and I've had that
if you can have the experience as a
meditator where you kind of go just
beyond your evolution right and you end
up you know thinking well I'm meditating
I should be okay with my best friend you
know dating my ex-girlfriend that I just
broke up with and you're really not okay
with that but you don't know it until
you kind of you know you're so you're
basically dancing on that line the
that the the fringe of their or the edge
I should say of being of being in the
unknown and kind of having some
familiarity as well and I think that's
where all the magic happens in life so
as you pull the layers back on your own
personal growth like what is it that
you're confronting right now or that you
struggle with the most
that's a very interesting question so
you don't have to answer no no no I
think it's important to keep it 100 here
yeah rich I you know I still I still
have thoughts about having a family I
have thoughts about having kids and it
hasn't appeared as though my life has
been going in that direction and you
know I wouldn't say I struggle with it
but I do wonder sometimes like am i
doing enough but then when I when I pull
the lens back and I see the effort that
I'm applying to all the other things and
how everything seems to be flowing it
reminds me that oh yeah I'm still in the
flow in this area and where I am is an
opportunity for you know whatever is
happening to continue happening so I
think there's there's got to be this
understanding that the ID the need that
you think you have individually is not
really your knee mm-hmm it's really
nature's need or a bigger need right and
when I look back at the relationships
that didn't work out for whatever reason
it's funny at the heel of all of those
relationships that's where I started to
shine that's where I started that's
where I became a meditation teacher
that's where I started writing my daily
dose of inspiration emails that I send
out every morning at 6 o'clock Pacific
time I send out these inspirational
emails which has been going on for
almost two years now and it all happened
after a relationship ended mm-hm so you
know I don't know if there's causation
or correlation here but there's
something about about the lack of
or at least appearing as I'm not moving
in that direction and and birthing these
things that are I think are having a
really positive effect in the world and
the reservation of self-judgement right
I mean it's all it's all there and I
think that's what's wonderful about it
you know you got to be relatable in some
way you can't have a perfect existence
with meditation or not and and so it's
all there and yeah and and I'm still in
the camera still rolling so I haven't
called cut yet right
speaking of calling come in here but
let's take us out with perhaps some some
words of wisdom to the person out there
who struggles with the idea of
meditation not sure how to start or
perhaps tried it but it didn't stick
what could you impart to that person
well I'm a little biased I would say you
know this book that I wrote bliss Moore
is the book I wish I would have had back
when I was living in New York sincerely
wanting to start meditating being
completely confused by what I was
experiencing and and I think that that
would be a good primer for anyone who
does not enjoy meditation other certain
people out there that enjoy their
meditation practice and this book wasn't
written for them but if you're wanting
to meditate and you already agree that
meditation is a great thing and you know
you you read all those studies and yet
you just can't quite find a path that
you feel excited about not just you're
okay with you excited about it then you
can start with that
otherwise I would just say start with
anything even if it's just 10 minutes
even if it's just 5 minutes start with
anything that you can do consistently
consistency is everything when it comes
to meditation if you're not doing it
every day then you try something else
until you get to something that you find
that you can do every day and once you
start doing it every day then you're
gonna start to see some changes in
inside and it may not necessarily show
up in the way that you think it should
show up for instance just last story
I'll tell here's I taught this guy who
came to me because he had
gastrointestinal problems and
are you vedic doctor told him you have
to start meditating first because when
you're stressed your digestive system is
not gonna work in the way that it should
work when I give you these herbs and and
other remedies so he comes he learns how
to meditate and when he shows up he's
got these big clunky shoes on and we
told him we had to take his shoes off
because that's what you do when you
learned to meditate you take your shoes
off
it's an old tradition and he said I
can't take my shoes off so we made an
exception we let him sit down first then
he took his shoes off the reason why he
couldn't remove his shoes was because he
had some metatarsal problems his and he
was wearing corrective shoes and he said
I can't even take one step without these
shoes on so he learns how to meditate
sends me an email a year later says like
you're not gonna believe this but I
found myself vacuuming my apartment the
other day and I wasn't wearing my shoes
there was no pain in my feet anymore and
the only thing I've been doing since I
met you was I started meditating and I
wasn't even looking for that to happen I
just figured I'd have to you know wear
these shoes for the rest of my life I've
been spending a fortune on these things
and you know I see that kind of thing
all the time where people think one
thing should be happening as a result of
the practice and yet they end up getting
something completely unexpected but even
more amazing than what they originally
were going for and it happens from
consistency though that guy he was in
his 60s never meditated a day in his
life he was meditating every day and and
it wasn't unusual to hear that kind of
report from someone like that so I would
just say you know try to be as
consistent as you can and be open to
whatever happens I love that example and
that is also that also perfectly
encapsulates Ayurveda right it's right
out it's about bringing in for bringing
mind body and spirit into harmony and
this guy has GI issues which he's
probably not connecting to the feet
problem that's right and and doctor says
start meditating understanding that it's
a it's a first step towards enhancing
that harmony that's what ends up being
the thing that like sort of sets
everything in motion for his body to
heal itself yeah yeah it's incredible
yeah but yeah it's hard to you know give
someone suggestions about improving
their life without meditation being a
part of that
right this again knowing what I know and
seeing what I've seen and it's just if
there was a pill that could do what
meditation could do you know whoever
invented that pill would become a
trillionaire in about a week because
there's literally no side effects aside
from you sitting there having some you
know rocky thoughts in the beginning of
your meditation practice but then after
a while even that starts to subside and
you know everyone's mind technically is
busy inside the side effect is that you
end up going to parties and telling all
your friends how great meditation try
and annoying them that's right that's
right that's right and you learn how to
stop doing that too I went through that
when I was a vegan I was vegan before
anybody in my circle was vegan and so
you learned pretty quickly you can't
can't force that on everybody alright
man well that was awesome bliss more is
the book I really enjoyed it you did a
great job man so everybody please pick
up the book and check it out it's an
easy read it's very accessible and I
love all the stories like the story you
just told it's all in there and I think
it will take anybody through the process
of acclimating to what is required of
you to step into this new lifestyle that
is clearly transformational so I
appreciate the work that you do and much
love brother thank you thank you again
for having me back on the pod mass it's
been good and if you want to connect
with light out light Watkins on Twitter
and Instagram light Watkins calm
great and if you want to sign up for his
inspirational daily emails by walk-ins
you also have begin meditating calm
right so what's going on there that's
for that's a meditation I think light
Watkins is just everything else books
and the and the talks and things like
that right and you're having headed to
New York is there a shine happening in
New York there's a shine happening in
New York next week yes man who's
speaking this be out by there probably
not okay yeah if you want to if you want
to attend a future shine yeah yeah
what's the shine where the shine
movement or movement or cool
who's speaking at the one in New York
we've got a woman who uh who was a
genocide survivor in Rwanda and she
ended up contracting HIV you know that
she was 13 years old when the
inside happened and saw her brother and
her her two brothers and her father get
killed and she survived that and so she
gives talks about no matter how dark
things get there's always hope wow
that's crazy man what is the what venue
that's gonna be at we work in Bryant
Park it's beautiful like sort of
Renaissance looking Ballroom cool man
awesome dude yeah that's exciting all
right excellent man and I have retreats
that I do a couple times a year and you
know meditate if you ever want to learn
with me in person there's ways to do
that as well but I would say start with
bliss more good man we'll come back and
let's talk more absolutely thank you all
right peace plants namaste
start meditating everybody
[Music]